nous sommes autorisés à entrer dans la zone les
caméras vérifiées sont bien allumées nous y allons
trois deux un
voici quelques g
il y a
bien c'était génial
je n'étais pas prêt à faire une suite tant que nous
n'avions pas une histoire spéciale
digne d'une suite et jusqu'à ce que la technologie
évolué pour que nous puissions approfondir
l'expérience d'un pilote de chasse,
le premier film est devenu quelque chose qui a
changé une génération,
donc c'est excitant de revenir et de monter
à nouveau dans ces jets,
nous avons travaillé avec la marine et la meilleure
école de tir pour formuler comment tirer  c'est
pratiquement parce que si nous allons le
faire, nous allons voler dans les f-18,
les séquences d'aviation devaient être réelles,
donc nos acteurs ont suivi trois mois
de formation au pouvoir,
la marine dit que si vous vous éjectez, vous
devez pouvoir  pour survivre dans l'eau, nous avons donc
dû suivre ce
programme sous-marin difficile,
c'est intense, vous êtes renversé et
vous devez essayer de sortir
de là. Tom a conçu
cette formation aéronautique
complète pour tous les actes.  ors
je les ai lancés dans un avion monomoteur
pour développer leur conscience spatiale
à l'intérieur de l'avion,
ensuite nous les avons emmenés au l-39 et ils
sont allés faire des acrobaties aériennes pour ressentir ce que
c'est que dans un jet à
partir de là, ils obtiendraient leur diplôme  le f-18
super hornet et le lancement d'
un porte-avions,
les acteurs ont également dû apprendre à faire fonctionner
les caméras car lorsqu'ils sont dans
le jet, ils doivent se diriger
essentiellement d'accord,
je devais vraiment leur apprendre la
cinématographie et l'éclairage  pour
qu'ils comprennent ce qui va bien paraître devant la
caméra,
tout le monde pensait qu'il serait impossible
pour les acteurs d'être vraiment dans les jets,
mais c'est le cadeau que Tom nous a donné
qu'au moment où nous sommes arrivés là-bas,
nous pouvions le gérer
définitivement le plus  chose incroyable que j'ai
jamais faite toute la formation 100 préparés
je suis très fier de ce que nous accomplissons tous
chacun d'eux est extraordinaire
ça me souffle toujours que nous avons fait
ça
il n'y a rien de tel
toi